let's go to our caller from the 9 to 0
area code caller from 9 to 0 who's there
I this is Donna hi Donna what's going on
well subject but it is I am familiar
with I've been around numbers so it's
not as identifiable but I'm familiar
with the 19 I mean uh $15,000,000,000
normally undetectable fraud which
equates this particular thing equates to
about seven billion dollars in on the
Contacts asset okay hold on a second
Donna let me let me back up because
you're shot out of a cannon today
what are you hard what's that what
what's 15 billion what are you talking
about there is a very large fraud that
is going on okay I have all of that the
evidence and I was just wondering about
if I sent it off to you being all the
information and the evidence and
everything I've already recorded it and
re-recorded it hold on hold on everybody
Donna would you be open for me just
talking you through this so that I can
understand it well yeah if you like okay
who is committing the fraud a large
financial company but oh you realize
because it's so so easy and because it's
undetectable hold on hold on hold on let
me walk through it step by step with you
just so we can all understand it a large
financial company is committing the
fraud who is the victim of the fraud
myself you have been defrauded by a
financial institution to the tune of did
you say 50 hold on Donna did you say
America all of us did you say 15 million
or 15 billion okay I know it sounds
crazy and loud are the Donna hold on now
let's not get ahead of ourselves what is
the financial product or mechanism
through which the fraud is being
committed for example are we talking
about investment fraud are we talking
about mortgage fraud no bankruptcy court
okay
normally and undetectable and how did
you detect it I was looking to refine it
well it happened in o8 okay I don't know
they're gonna identify they're gonna
know um and I was gonna try to refinance
my home but because I had conflict of
interest attorneys they didn't let that
but so in order to do that I had to
search under the court system and this
time I searched honor my name instead of
a case number and so when I searched
under my name I saw this billion-dollar
thing and they pretended it to be and I
knew I didn't do anything wrong and now
hold on done at your time you're giving
us too much information at once when you
say you searched under your name your
first name is quite common Donna is it
possible that when you search under your
name things are coming up that relate to
other people that share your name is
that at all possible
no because they pretended it to be a
mistake yes the large financial
institution pretended it was a mistake
and but yet they took it off on their
SEC 10 Q 10 K it was right at the end of
their fiscal year they just squeeze it
right in at the 10 day transaction what
is it trans what is a 10 day transit a
fraud the fraud
okay thank Donna which attorneys were
representing you in this well you know I
had conflict of interest attorneys that
were hired paid for by the company that
was doing that so what you're saying is
the company committing the fraud against
you hired attorneys for you well they
just paid the attorneys correct why
would they do that okay well I guess you
need a name you need to know more and
it's probably better if I just send you
the information and that's why I'm
calling
where would I see if you like where
would I send it because I'm my my
feeling just so you know is that this is
so easy
to be done and it's normally
undetectable so what the thing is we
would have trillions of dollars hitting
our reducing our debt hold on 15 how do
we go from 15 billion to having
trillions if you realize that
accountants large accountants you know
across the u.s. there's like four of
them and you know if one knows about it
they're gonna do it for other companies
and you have a big paychecks for
everybody and so if you look at just 5%
of corporations doing this kind of thing
it equals like three trillion dollars
all right Donna listen I'm gonna tell
you that truth I'm concerned about you
I'm concerned about you I'm not sure
about what you're telling me but but I
I'm concerned about you and you know you
can send the information if you have it
but I don't know that this is a story
for me but but feel free to send it I'm
gonna let you go Donna Donna seems to be
struggling and I I do feel bad